good morning John it's Esther day a day
in our community and ideally in the
whole world where we celebrate
non-romantic law when we call on people
to tell the folks that they love that
they love them even if it is a little
awkward like John I love you I
appreciate you to me you will always be
a big deal no matter what and I want to
work hard to have you always be a part
of my life if that what love is I also
asked on Twitter this week if people had
questions about family and friends
because I wanted to use people's
questions to kind of get something I've
been thinking about a lot and it worked
let's start out with a few easy ones
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
caught John doing like besides
sponsoring a third tier English soccer
team nothing that is the weirdest thing
what's a cute oran story in the morning
sometimes he looks at me and he says
Papa Nana which is actually sentence
that means pick me up up up take me
downstairs da and feed me a banana Papa
Donna how do you know when it's the
right ish time to have a baby I actually
made a whole video about this but I
mostly want to answer this question
because then this person's mom replied
to her and said ask your mom if she's
ready to be a grandma no no bad mom no
how do you stay in touch with family
when you're separated by a long distance
is one of three ways one you could just
happen to have all of the same free time
and all of the same desires for
communication that's not gonna happen
- you could do what I did all throughout
college and you let the person who wants
to talk more guilt you or nag you into
calling them which creates resentment or
3 you can schedule it just schedule it
have it on the calendar so nobody is
having their expectations upset
relationships are work do the work
speaking of which here's the actual
question that I wanted to answer in this
video they knew it was gonna get it a
lot and I've been thinking a lot about
it how do you make friends as an adult I
also see people answer this question
incorrectly a lot those answers usually
go something like you got to put
yourself in places where you will
interact with other people volunteer
take a class go to a protest bring your
neighbors cookies if you got kids go to
kid things all that stuff's fine advice
I just don't think that it gets to the
root of the problem I'm gonna go ahead
and get pretty real here when you're
young you make friends easily because
you find it very easy to value other
people like the kid next door when
you're growing up you implicitly believe
that they're a big deal and what they
think about you matters and likewise
they feel the same way about you and
when two people each agree on the others
intrinsic importance they work together
to maintain a relationship and respect
and appreciation and that's friendship
at least as far as I can tell I'm sorry
I think about these things very
rationally but it's how it works up in
here as we get older and we're exposed
to more people who might not be worth
being friends with and we also start to
value other things like romantic love or
money or power or likes on Instagram I
think and this is just guessing we're
less likely to quickly value other
people and less likely to be quickly
valued by others I think when we ask why
is it harder to make friends as an adult
what we're really asking is why is it
harder to value and be valued by others
but I actually don't think that it is
harder I think that we just forgot how
hard we used to work for it none of this
answered the question but I feel like
understanding the question better might
help us each individually answer it
better for ourselves you want to make
friends as an adult you have to figure
out how to really value other people and
to get them to believe that it matters
how much you value them because look
we're all on this messed-up 2018
together and sometimes you're gonna put
energy in and in and in and never get
any bad that can hit your confidence
pretty hard and then you stop trying you
got to understand that there are so many
non social and quasi social things
taking up our cognitive resources that
it makes sense that people aren't giving
back when you give we kind of sometimes
don't have the time and energy to devote
to valuing individuals in our lives and
that's a little bit of a disaster
because that's what friendship is and
that's what love is and while this video
has a lot of guessing in it that's
something that I know love is not free
it takes a devotion of time and energy
it takes work and I wanted to say to all
of my friends and family thank you for
helping make that labor joyful John I'll
see you on Tuesday